[Music]
hey on today's show we talked to a young
man whose wife has bipolar disorder and
he wants to know some things he can do
to help her out
we also talked to a woman whose dad
announced to her younger sister mom's
been cheating on me and she wants to
know what she can do
and finally we talk to a young woman
who's trapped
in the middle of a family business and
the family drama that goes with it
and by the way we may talk about whether
santa claus is real or not so if you
want this to be the moment for your kids
have everybody stay tuned
[Music]
dude i'm deloney and welcome to the dr
john dolone show
this show is about you your lives the
good
the bad the ugly you ain't got no alibi
when things are smelling like roses and
when things are smelling
like a giant box of f-a-r-t-s
i've been walking alongside folks just
like you for two decades
whether your life is just doing great or
you're sitting in the ashes of a
burned-out mess
i've been there i've seen it and i'm
here to
walk alongside you and i've committed my
life i've committed my life trying to
figure out what's going on in my life
and my marriage and my home with my kids
and how i can help you walk alongside
the people that you love the people you
interact with the people you don't like
and feel how we can learn how to be
people again
and especially be okay with that
angry sad frustrated or just overjoyed
person that we see in the mirror
so if you're new to our band of ninjas
we talk about everything on the show
from mental health challenges to your
marriage
to parenting to what you eat relational
iq questions schooling education
everything and sometimes
like today we've got to pause and say
enough
is freaking enough
with the new 2021 planners in all of
these stupid
ribbons in all of the day planners
people
enough i saw a new day planner it had
711 different colored ribbons in it one
for the new goal for the day and then
you go back to the next one
and then you flip the other ribbon
around and then you braid them and then
you
slap it up flip it rub it down oh no all
these ribbons so there's another one and
then another one and then another one
all of them have too many ribbons look
good folks
give me ribbons during this yellow pad
zero or on a note card
zero my friend christy wright her
journal zero
you can make a rat super
productive good annual journal with
zero ribbons or maybe one if you just
want to know where you're gonna be
they used to call that a um bookmark
that's back in the old days when we had
just books with one ribbon in it
one ribbon let's call it good so
whatever's going on in your life give me
a call
at six nine 1-844-693 thirty two ninety
one
that's one eight four four six nine
three thirty two ninety one
or you can go to johndaloni.com show
and seriously i if you're making
journals
you're already thinking about the
journal for 2022
enough with the ribbons i'm gonna keep
going back to that
enough of the ribbons all right let's go
let's see here
let's just go right to the phones let's
do that let's go to ben in niagara falls
in
ontario ben what's up brother how are
you doing
hi marie how are you i'm doing so good
how's niagara falls
uh it's not bad it's about zero degrees
and it's pretty good
it's about zero degrees it is just
under 50 here in nashville and the city
shut down
they pretty much think it's over here
and that they were lied to hell is
actually frozen
and it is upon us right zero degrees
that's so
that's wild well you're you guys call it
32.
ah well played i see what you did there
that was good i i support that joke that
was good
and you're on the beautiful side of
niagara falls is that right
yeah we called the beautiful side yeah i
do too i went up there when i was a
young child there's
the sad lonely side and there's the
beautiful stunning
vegas side so that's what where you are
so that's very cool so brother ben how
can i help man
um well my my wife has like she's
diagnosed with bipolar type one
okay um and so she has some problems
like overspending with groceries and
stuff like that even when she has a list
um so we've been trying to do cash um
but i like i i don't want it when we
explain it to family that i'm holding on
to a debit card i don't want it
just to come off as controlling um
so like how do i kind of balance those
two out
they're like that out man that's a great
question so let's do this
for the listeners i get a lot of
questions and a lot of calls
about bipolar disorder um
and so there's type one right which is
what we think of the traditional manic
depressive
real high highs can do anything in two
or three days that takes most of us a
couple of weeks to do
and then really low lows um not getting
out of bed for
days and weeks at a time and making
decisions that when folks are manic when
they're
in a depressed state that normally they
wouldn't make
and then there's the type 2 which is the
hypomania the highs aren't quite as high
lows aren't quite as low depending on
where you may fall on that trajectory
there's some literature that suggests
type 1 is
is like schizophrenia it's a true mental
health
disorder and and bipolar 2 is more of a
learned responsive behavior
um but but they're still arguing about
that up in their
laboratories and so i'd love for you to
just walk through for the average
listener
what's it like being married to somebody
with diagnosed type one
um well it's
it's it's hard to keep track of
sometimes um
but it's it's like we've been trying to
to get on the on the dave ramsey program
and
it's just if i give her a debit card
then sometimes like she'll go to costco
for like
maybe like 150 and stuff and she'll come
back with 400
saying well we need this this and this
and it sort of makes sense
um yeah it sort of makes sense the
argument that she's making
but it's not necessary if that sort of
makes sense
so let's i i want to talk not about
money for just a second i want to know
what it's like being married to someone
with bipolar disorder outside of the
money
walk through somebody who wouldn't
wouldn't have the first they wouldn't
know the first thing about
being married to somebody who's um just
lives on that up and down cycle what's
that what's that like what's your
marriage like what is your dating life
what is
uh well like if it when things are good
it's it's fantastic but like when things
are bad it's like
it's like wars going on you know and
what's the thing that's bad
give us an example so like if she gets
into a low
um everything will throw her off um
like we were having breakfast the other
day and she was just
she was kind of feeling you know low but
she wasn't sure if she was like in a
in a right down depressive low um and we
were having breakfast we were having
eggs
and she dropped one of the eggs which
isn't that big of a deal because like we
can just clean it up there's no problem
and she just started to cry and and that
like that was just the end of the end of
her day and you know it was like it was
9 30 in the morning we're just
having breakfast and her day was over
right
um and so with stuff like that
you just like i i try to you know kind
of just be like okay calm down
like everything's okay it's just an egg
never say those words ever again as long
as you live okay
that's between you and me you don't even
call for that never say the words calm
down
right um well i i i don't physically say
it but i just
like try to like help her through it
right you know i ask her like
like what's going on how are you feeling
you know we try to just bring the
situation to uh
like a normal like a level playing field
if that sort of makes sense
so it sounds like she won the lottery
because she married somebody who loves
her regardless of the challenges that
she faces before she's got a guy who
has devoted his life to her and he's
working to figure that out is that fair
well i mean i i went through my own uh
depression and suicide
uh stint for for a couple years
um and she's stuck with me through that
as well
um well i'm doing way better now hold on
i'm trying to say something nice about
you ben
don't deflect okay can i say something
nice about you sure
all right sounds like she married a guy
who loves her and is
doing his best to support her and care
for her
is that fair yeah all right so all the
way from nashville to ontario brother i
want to high five you and tell you that
i wish there were more guys like you out
in the world and i'm glad that you're
i'm glad that you are walking alongside
her during a tough season
and that you are leaning in and
investing in
um helping her be whole so good for you
brother
so as it comes to the reason why you
called
talking about debit cards has has her
family actually told you hey we think
this is nonsense this controlling
behavior or is this stuff that you're
imagining into the future might happen
someday
well yeah i think i'm more imagining it
like nobody's
come right out and told me um but but
she's told me that she kind of feels
like a child with it as well
um so that like that's where i'm
i i don't really know how to approach it
sure does that make sense
yeah so when you came up with the debit
card so it's just for folks listening
folks especially with type one bipolar
spending
is um it's a great dopamine release it's
a common thing that folks do when
they're manic they will take their money
they will actually earn a lot of money
they do well
and then they go just spend it like
matter if they don't have money they
will
charge up obscene amounts of money
during a manic state and then they will
begin to get these bills in
and that will help facilitate a fall
into a depressive state once they
realize the shame and the
they experience this in in really deep
ways
so one of the things that we when we're
talking with bipolar is they've got to
set up especially if they're going to be
um taking getting counseling if they're
going to be taking medication
and they're going to be actively
involved in getting better they've got
to set up some
really high hurdles for themselves some
strong roadblocks for
getting well somebody who overspends is
going to give away
their ability to spend in their more
lucid state when they are well
and whole they're gonna say i understand
that
um i'm not capable of controlling myself
during the season i'm gonna give that
away they gotta come up with different
behaviors
and someone who loves them is gonna hold
them accountable whether it's a friend
it's a
husband like you is gonna take their
debit card and hang on to it
then there's gonna be low seasons where
they come after you or super high
seasons where they come after you
i feel like a baby you're treating me
like i'm a child whatever
and that's when someone who loves
somebody with bipolar has to hang on and
weather that storm
my guess is ben if you told her family
that y'all had talked through this and
you know we're working together
and that this is one of the strategies
y'all came up with they would celebrate
you
is there a chance that would happen that
they'd they would think oh that's
awesome ben way to go
or are they gonna they gonna side with
her
and say you're a jerk trying to control
her daughter
no i i think they i think they might uh
they might agree with it
um because they've seen her spending
behaviors as well there you go
so i ben i think you're in a win here
and i think you're projecting
a potential negative outcome out in the
into the future
here's what i'd recommend man if your
wife is cool with it as y'all
co-create when i say co-create i mean
y'all are making this plan together
because she's got to be
invested in getting well and doing all
the things whether that's exercise
whether that is a
accountability routine that when she is
super super low that someone's going to
walk in and y'all going to go for a walk
together
where she's really high someone's going
to say hey we're clocking out of work
today
whatever that looks like we're going to
eat we're going to change our diet so
that these highs aren't maybe aren't
quite so high aren't quite so low in
conjunction with medication that some
folks with type 1 have to be on forever
that's a part of a total wellness plan
that you
and her and a doctor are going to work
together on but if she's amenable to it
get her family involved too there can't
be too many people
as in in a helping circle for somebody
who's struggling with bipolar
unless that family was a part of the
original problem in the first place
and so if her family has been abusive
or obnoxious or idiots or destructive
over the course of her life then of
course don't bring them in and here's
the final thing brother
if you and your wife are working
together to create a life where y'all
can both be well both be whole
who cares what her parents say when you
got married
their voice went to number two or
sometimes way down to the bottom of that
list
i don't care what they have to say if
it's working for you and your wife then
it's working for you and your wife
and so good for you for being a husband
who cares um
whatever that the behaviors have to have
to be um i've i've read
or discussed with folks who have to take
every shred of alcohol out of the house
have to take cash out of the house have
to take their their partner's debit card
have to take car keys there's all sorts
of behaviors when someone is
learning new coping behaviors and
sometimes with bipolar takes a season to
do that
in a season it could be six months could
be a year it could be two years it could
be several years
you gotta you sometimes have to be
extreme and then those who play
accountability you gotta weather that
storm because they're gonna come after
you
because that's that's the nature of this
beast and you gotta stand strong so good
for you
all right let's go to kelly in nashville
kelly what's going on in nashville how
are you
hi dr john i'm doing good how are you
good i just said like how's nashville
like it's really far away it's i'm i'm
down the street from you probably some
shape form or fashion but
um so are you enjoying the snow is this
wild or what
um well i'm originally from ohio so i
came down here to get away from the snow
this is like mid august for you so
that's cool all right all right kelly so
what's going on how can i help
so um almost 10 years ago
we found out that my mom had been having
an affair with a man in the neighborhood
and obviously things were tense for a
little bit but my parents decided to
stay together
and work things out since that time
neither of them
from my excuse me point of view
have really made any significant changes
or efforts towards a healthier marriage
so um i guess flash forward a couple
days before christmas
i got a call from my sister saying that
my dad had found
more emails that my mom had sent to this
man
and my sister felt the pressure kind of
not to say anything
to me but really to either
well my other sibling um so
but she couldn't really carry it all by
herself so she was obviously telling me
um and since that time she's admitted to
my dad that she did tell me
and so she was kind of pulled in as a
mediator
at the moment and um
i you know and so then i was the support
for the mediator in secret
what a mess hey so real quick real quick
so did your mom kick back up this affair
with this dude or did your dad find
stuff from 10 years ago no it's back
uh okay and the way you said it the dude
in the neighborhood so the dude in the
neighborhood still
is in the neighborhood and so he's he's
back in action right
mm-hmm and how old how old are you i'm
29.
okay and how old your little sister
uh 26. okay
so we're all adults um
except except for your parents but go
ahead
well right um well and so my
my sister since admitted to my dad that
um she told me
so you know my dad followed up with me
and um
kind of got i guess my thoughts on the
situation
i don't know if anyone has told my
brother or not
i did also end up reaching out to my mom
to just to let her know that
i still love her and i still support her
but really my question today i'm just
trying to figure out
what is my responsibility in this
situation
to my family as a whole and then
you know what's my responsibility to my
mom my dad
my brother my sister each as individuals
that's a great question and just for the
record i hate that you got drawn into
this i hate that your
dad did that to your sister and
triangulated her in that way he should
have some friends and some confidants
and or a counselor or a place where he
can go and talk to grown-ups about these
challenges but um and i hate that for
your sister and
your poor brother how old is he
uh he's 27. yeah and leave it to the
brother just like hey everybody what
y'all doing
ryan has no idea just be bopping along
right exactly
so um here's my thought
thought number one is secrets
destroy families period and
my guess is if there has been um 10
years absence here and there's been no
reconnection and all i would tell you as
much as you think you know and you can
see
you probably know 25 to 35 percent of
what actually goes on behind closed
doors with your mom and dad
and so what i would challenge you with
is staying out of the
you all didn't do any work the judge the
judgment part of what went on behind
closed doors
um because that's going to make you nuts
and it's going to make your parents have
to fight their kids
and don't do that to them unfortunately
you're forced to be the adult here
if i'm you um and i've got a sister and
a brother
i would call them we'd have a three-way
talk and we would talk it out and let
everybody be on the same page because
i'm not gonna hold secrets from my
brother and sister because i'm an adult
and um if my dad were to call me and
burden me with that
i would let him know i'm gonna let my
brother and sister know
because i'm not your therapist and i'm
not bound by confidentiality now i'm not
gonna go tell the neighborhood right but
i am not gonna hold secrets so that
we're all together and we're all on
different pages and different stories i
think what you did for your mom is to
let her know that you love her
is noble i think that's good she's going
to need some support
i also think it's good for you to let
your dad know that you love him
what i would do is send them both a
something in writing
your mom and your dad at the same time
that says we all know
we're not gonna get involved in your
marriage um
i don't and you can feel free to say
what's on your heart and your mind
but let them know we are not going to be
triangulated into this mess
they are responsible for dealing with
their marriage and um they're
responsible for dealing with their
relationship with each other
and the dude in the neighborhood and
whoever else and whatever else
but you can't solve that you can't get
in the middle of it and all you're going
to do
is wage war with your brother and sister
and your family
and at this point you've got to be the
grown up in that deal
i and know i'm telling you to do
something hard which is to not get right
down in the middle of that mud because
that's tempting isn't it
yeah yeah um are you angry with any
any one of them or both of them
um are heartbroken what are you feeling
[Applause]
my sister kept telling me she thought
that i was kind of emotionally
disconnected
from the situation because i think 10
years ago when it happened
i kind of came to terms well
maybe i didn't maybe i just repressed it
but i felt like i'd kind of come to
terms with
maybe they'll stay together maybe they
won't but
i think the thing that kind of kept me
going was knowing that
regardless god was still faithful in my
life
regardless of what happened so that was
kind of my anchor
and my
i was real close with both of them
growing up
um i think my dad and i in the past year
or so
um have kind of butt heads sometimes a
little
um uh so there's part of me that's angry
with him because i've seen
some of the ways that uh he's
hurt my mom and like he said
you know i've probably not seen all of
it obviously it goes both ways
um so that in some degrees has made me
angry at him
with my mom i've been angry um number
one because she's so good at being
sneaky
and you know i i never knew how sneaky
she was
and so just seeing that and realizing
that now but
um can i tell you something you you
maybe didn't know how sneaky she was
but i promise the 16 year old um
kelly absorbed it
you knew it and my guess is if you go
back to
12 year old kelly an 11 year old kelly
were things just rosy and wonderful at
the house
and they were i thought i had the
perfect family growing up there you go
okay
and so you absorbed that and um
yeah man that's tough to unwind
and so when you were 19 and this came
out did it just blow your mind
oh yeah definitely how'd you find out
um so my so
the guy that she cheated with um asked
to meet my dad at a mcdonald's
in the area oh dude
that's a brave guy
well no sorry it was his wife um
that told my dad and so i knew
he was going and when he came back you
know obviously something was wrong
i had no idea it was so the dude in the
neighborhoods i feel like i'm like we're
middle schoolers now so the dude in the
neighborhood
the dude in the neighborhood called your
dad no the dude in the neighborhood's
wife calls your dad to meet at
a diabetes factory and they met there
and that's where they told him
yeah from my from my recollection that
that's how my time dude that is so 10
years ago because right now he would
just text
that's it so good for them i don't think
my dad probably
suspected sure he just didn't have the
proof
and this other guy's wife brought the
proof okay
so so fast forward to now i i can get
distracted pretty easily with that story
because that just sounds like there's
layer after layer after layer of that
one
here's the deal you hear me say this all
the time
you're gonna have to grieve that story
and you had a perfect family and they
weren't perfect there is no perfect
family
and your dad made some decisions your
mom made some decisions
the the neighbor the dude in the
neighborhood
his wife at the mcdonald everybody made
decisions here and
are you married now yes okay um
you're gonna have to have some honest
conversations with your husband you're
gonna have to have some honest
conversations with your brothers and
sisters
and again going back to my original
thing i would put in writing to my mom
and dad
here's we all know we are all we love
you
we are not getting in the middle of this
mess and if you all don't act like
adults
and deal with this mess in a way that is
whole for everybody then y'all are
opting out of thanksgiving because we're
all getting together
and y'all are opting out of christmas
get togethers because we're all getting
together
and we're going to mourn the loss of the
family that we thought we had
um but we're not gonna get sucked into
this thing
and so dad you're not calling little
sister to gossip about mom and mom
you're not calling
middle brother to talk about if your dad
had only we're not doing that we're not
playing that game
and um the reason i tell you to write a
letter
is that way they can go back to it over
and over and over again
and when people are having hard
conversations with one another
especially family members
old roles pop up old stories pop up old
defense mechanisms pop up and we start
hearing only what we want to hear
and there's something about having a
letter that you can go back to and go
back to and go back to
okay and it will probably be a heavy
thing for them to read and they'll read
it two
three four times and they may text you
and say who the crap you think you
are and you can tell them i'm your
oldest daughter and i love you guys
and you can just sit with that but i'll
tell you um
you are going to have to kelly go
through your own grieving process here
and you may have
everybody grieves differently your
brother may break down on all like just
be comatose weeping and you may say that
really
sucks i'm pissed at my mom pissed my dad
you morons you blew up something great
and um i hope you're all happy and i'm
moving on about my life because my
marriage is good too that may be awesome
may be good
or you may find sneaky tendencies in
yourself and you may
find that you slowly start to fill x
or y or z or you may find yourself
starting to respond to problems between
you and your husband or challenges that
we all have
kind of like your dad maybe a little
loud a little aggressive a little angry
and when you have those seasons you've
got to commit now to making sure that
you don't repeat that cycle with your
husband
and then be open to your brother and
sister man make sure that they've got a
place to call which can be you
um and make sure you love them but that
just sucks i hate that for you
and again i say this all the time
parents out there don't treat your kids
like your therapist man that's not what
they're for don't treat
it drives me crazy when people say um
you know my son he's 14 we're best
friends i'm best friends with my dad
i was thinking what's so weird dude have
friends your own age
um if i was to go out in the
neighborhood and be like hey was my best
friend he's 14
i'd go to jail because that's i probably
go to jail but that's just weird
right have friends your own age and if
you've been cheating on your spouse
don't make the first call to your 21
year old daughter talk to a pastor talk
to a friend
talk to i don't know maybe your husband
would be a good person to talk to you
talk to a counselor but talk to people
who are equipped with this
don't dump that type of nonsense onto
your children man that's so much
if you have six-year-old kids don't talk
about your marriage problems your
six-year-old kids
why because they're six and dragons are
still maybe kinda real
and so is santa and they don't even know
about dad or they don't need to
don't do that to your children okay get
people who are grown-ups you can be
vulnerable with
and what i find often is that it's hard
for grown-ups to be vulnerable
you owe it to your kids to not dump this
crap onto them okay
and that brings me to this i get this
question a lot because i say this
probably
too much i say the phrase not by your
hand but in your lap i say that all the
time
people always like what do you mean
james and kelly and they'll be like yeah
you say that all the freaking time we're
super annoyed by it and then zach's just
thumbs up in me all the it's awesome um
here's what i mean by not by your hand
but in your lap i mean
we all go through life
trying to do the best we can with the
tools we got and
not every once in a while but often a
politician does something stupid
a somebody backs into your car um
you eat a salad and the lettuce in that
salad
has e coli on it and now you've got
rocket diarrhea right you didn't do that
on purpose
it happened and we are so obsessed in
this culture
so obsessed with blame and blame
and blame and whose fault and who's this
and some things are direct
sometimes the guy backed up and hit your
car because he's a [ __ ]
he's just an idiot and he wasn't paying
attention and
sometimes um it just rains really hard
and your house floods
right or sometimes you just go get a
salad and i
promise you the company that wasn't
trying to make you sick
hopefully they were following the rules
and you got it just happened so what i
mean is not by your hand but in your lap
meaning you didn't cause it but it just
is and what are you gonna do about it
in so much of the time in our culture in
our lives and our personal lives and our
homes
somebody does something whether
intentional or unintentional and it
happens to us and then we just go
um i just i can't believe that happened
i can't believe they did that
and then we just sit there and what i
am constantly telling myself constantly
telling people i love
and you is great solve the problem
like my son if he's pouring milk and he
accidentally drops the milk jug and it
just falls
the tendency to sit there and watch it
fall nobody's mad nobody's upset but we
got to solve that problem and right now
the milk is spilling everywhere let's
just get that up right
the house is flooding well it could be
because of this and those developers
dude the house is flooding let's solve
that problem and then we'll get to the
other stuff later
okay so what i mean by this is if you're
a 26 year old
and you're about to go to christmas you
have been through 2021 and it
sucks and i mean 2020 well 2021 is not
just launching out of the gates really
great um
but you can't wait for the holidays and
then your dad calls and he's like guess
what i found
that's not by your hand but in your lap
you didn't need to get that email or
that phone call from your
dad you did and now you've got to deal
with it and you've got to be the adult
in this situation
and you can join in by gossiping you can
join in by talking crap about mom you
can join him by being dramatic or
you can be the adult you can draw the
boundary line and say that's between you
and mom
we're super not cool with both of you
right now it's just frustrating this is
annoying i'm going to talk to my brother
and sister
because i'm not keeping secrets in this
family i refuse to do that
and we're going to be the grown-ups here
and we love you both but y'all need to
get your crap together
and um we're going to talk about
alternative thanksgivings and
christmases until y'all too decide to be
grown-ups
and that's what i mean by not by your
hand but in your lap stop with the blame
first
solve the problems first and then we'll
get back to the blame now there's some
things we can't
i get it but most of the time solve the
problem
solve it and then we'll move on okay all
right let's go to
um liz in san luis obispo california
liz what's going on hello dr
d how are you thank you i'm great i have
a quick quiz
oh sure oh number one you're about to
say something nice
thank you for calling i was just gonna
say thank you well
i'm saying thank you to you and quick
quiz my favorite ufc fighter of all time
is from san luis obispo who is it if you
get this
i'm going to send you an autographed
copy of this book who is it
i have no idea say chocoladelle
chuck liddell oh my gosh your genius
list congratulations stand in the line
after this call
and kelly will get you a book sent out
you're a genius and i'm it's
making my whole day to talk to you
congratulations it's awesome okay so
what's going on how can i help
well my question has to do with my
relationship with my co-workers
i'm i am an independent contractor
and have found myself to be the
middleman
between the author founder of the
program and her daughter
who is the ceo oh lord on a stick in a
box
she's always that's not great
you probably can tell where i'm going
with this so i feel like
this show is brought to you by days of
our lives this has been awesome the
whole show but go ahead
or dawson's creek which is the best go
ahead
i so i was hired by the cta by the ceo
to help her move the company and the
product forward like with technology
social media et cetera all the kinds of
stuff that the author
either doesn't understand doesn't want
or
doesn't or wants to do it her own exact
way
so throw in a very strained
mother-daughter relationship
and it's a recipe for anxiety for me
yeah
especially especially when i talk to the
ceo
because she reminds me so much of my mom
who
i also have a strained relationship with
that's just a side note
so well i would actually flip that
around my guess is your anxiety comes
from that fractured relationship
that this one reflects not vice versa
but that's a whole other show so
continue
so um they both talk openly
about conflicts and feelings that they
have regarding the other person
and the the author gets pretty mad when
i disagree with her about something
and wants me to basically follow blindly
her directions even when they go against
what the
ceo has told me so
the reason i contacted you is
to see if you could help me with setting
better boundaries with both of them
without
being rude first of all and keeping my
job because i like my job a lot
and um just i i want to get out of the
triangle
i don't know how to do it uh that's such
a great question
um so and just one more thing
um the author still really wants to be
involved in the day-to-day
of course but she really needs to step
back
right so um
it sounds like you have a good
relationship with her daughter is that
fair
so what would it look like for you to go
out for coffee
or i don't know what you're allowed to
do in california but to um
to uh i don't i really don't have a zoom
call
um to talk to her and just say hey
starting off 2021 i'm
i'm caught in the middle of this wonky
relationship with y'all too
i love love this job i love love you
it's getting weird
can you give me some guidance if you
just approached it head on direct like
that
in a humble kind way what would she say
it's getting weird i like that word
track
and here's why i don't want you to go i
don't i don't want you
if you use words like this sucks or this
is bad or this is wrong
all three may be true but you're talking
about her
mom right and she can talk about about
her mom but probably you can't
right correct and also
she gets weird she knows it's weird and
if you call it out in a gentle humble
way
then that's different than an attack
right and then somebody can hear
a gentle humble like you're asking her
for advice you're not saying that her
mom's an idiot right
right and yeah i think you're right i
would get out of this triangulation at
some point this comes down
and you're the fall guy just so you know
okay
a hundred percent chance this ends badly
and you're the one that ends the worst
four
because mom's not going to fire daughter
or she is but it's going to be your
fault and
you're going to get blamed for it or
vice versa daughter who's running the
company is going to get rid of the
original author
right because that's mom and so you
become the weak link of this triangle
and the whole thing implodes on you and
yikes i
never thought about it you have to be
the natural fall guy because or fall gal
here because
they may bicker about each other and not
like each other but that's still mom and
that's still daughter
and you will never be that yeah right
and so
here's here's a ugly reality check you
may not want to not have this job it may
be awesome
and it may not be in the cards for you
to have it much longer
and then that's not cool or not fun but
that may just be straight up reality
i guess i could see that happening
it's with by your silence it sounds like
you know this is inevitable
right well not really i mean it makes
sense what you say
and i i totally i trust your knowledge
and
this type of stuff for sure but we have
had conversations the ceo
and i about where we both want to see
this company
going and how to get there and
but if mom is still driving if mom is
the author originator she owns the
patent
she's the governor here man we can have
all the dreams
you know what i super want next year two
million dollars
i want that so bad and i want a pony
that can fly because my daughter would
think i
ruled and if i could have like a
life-size lego thing for my son would be
right like a x-wing one of those star
wars
machine things that goes that'd be
awesome too
my wife would like a husband with way
more abs than i had all that would be
awesome
um but then there's that reality part
right
and so yeah dude those dreaming
conversations with the ceo are so great
and here's what we could do if mom would
just get out of the way the problems
mom's not getting out of the way
yeah at least not at her own accord
right
and man you want to see you guys have
had a lot of fires in your area this
year
you want to see a big one watch the
daughter ceo fi
fire her mom who is the original author
of this thing
no thanks right yeah so i again i'm
playing
nuclear option here but i think this
whole thing starts with an honest hey
this thing just feels weird and it feels
like it's getting weirder can you help
me
and um i love your mom i love you
i love love this job and i love the
mission of this company love where we're
headed
but this is starting to get super weird
for me and i don't know what to do next
and let her coach you and at some point
if it gets super gnarly with mom
then you're able to say i'm just simply
doing like a me and
and ceo talked through this and so we
came up with a game plan here
um and at that point you were
redirecting to the ceo where that those
kind of challenges go anyway
is that fair yeah that's fair
so you do me a humongous yes i'm having
a i confess i'm having a hard time
believing you what what's that believe
in me
i don't want to oh yeah i don't want to
be the fall guy
i i i want to not believe me that i'm
going to have two million dollars next
year i'm gonna have to sell a lot of
these ten dollar books to get two
million dollars next year i've sell a
lot of them
right so all that to say it's probably
not gonna happen for me
um maybe you're gonna be the one you're
not i'm just trying to be all nice and
kind you're not you will be the fall guy
100
and if you feel comfortable enough with
the ceo in that conversation tell her
i don't want to be the fall guy in this
deal i don't want this when this is
going to go south and i don't see a way
where it's not
i'm stuck in the middle here and i love
you both and i love this job and i don't
want to be the person
that ends up on fire here when this
thing crashes
and hopefully that ceo's is um a leader
on
a woman of character and she's gonna see
this and be like oh my gosh we have
drawn you into our drama
and um it's been a mess since we were a
little i was a little kid
it's still a mess this is not your fight
i'm so sorry i'm gonna do a better job
of
getting you out of the direct fire here
and by the way liz
free advice you didn't even call for
that's what we do on this show free
advice
um worth the price that you pay for it
maybe lean in and start um figuring out
ways you can heal the relationship with
your mom
at least you're part of it um she may
not
have any interest in wanting to
reconnect or to heal
a lifetime of a messed up relationship
but man
that gives you some peace moving forward
in your life to have that
um that tether reconnected there with
your mom
i'd love to see that happen but liz
please please after you have that
conversation with the ceo call me back
um if you have that conversation and you
get fired
one that'll suck i'll be sorry about
that but two i'll send you another book
and you can just
you can read both of them at the same
time that's all i can really offer you
but hang on the line kelly's going to
get you a
book for guessing chocolate chuck
liddell my favorite ufc fighter of all
time
and as you wrap up the show hey listen
this happened the other day so my buddy
one of my oldest friend best friends in
the world his name's todd
he calls me on the phone and he's
old man laughing like from his guts
laughing right when i answer it and i
knew it's gonna be awesome i was like
what's so funny
and he goes i just listened to one of
the stupidest things i've ever heard and
i was like oh what is this that was a
youtube clip
he said it was your ama episode where
you talked about
meditating and i was like what do you
mean that's stupid you're stupid
and he is laughing he's like i've known
you for almost 30 years
you don't meditate you told all those
people you meditate and i was like what
do you talk yeah i do every day
and i snapped a picture of i was down in
my basement i snapped a picture
where it had my little bell and the
pillow that i sit on all the stuff my
little
kumbaya journal my gratitude all that
and i sent it to him and he's laughing
even harder he's like are you
being serious he thought i was just
lying to everybody on the podcast
and i was like yeah i'm being serious
man that's why i'm so much better at
life than you
are and everything you touch is disaster
and everything that i'm a part of is
good because i'm calm
and cool because i meditate all the time
and so he's laughing and he's like
i can't wrap my head around my hyper
obnoxious delony fred
sitting down and being calm and still so
that leads me to this good folks
todd and everybody the song of the day
one of the greatest songs ever and it's
from the 70s
and by 70s i mean 1570s
it's called sub tomb president
comma anton a mode 7
it's a gregorian chant and it goes like
this
that's the end of the show i don't know
[Music]
you